hurricane durian packing sustained winds
close to 300 km/h is battering the
Bahamas this is one of the most powerful
storms to hit this nation and it's
predicted to linger for hours with
coastal surges in excess of 6 meters
despite pleas some residents have
decided to ride the storm out a decision
officials say could put their lives at
risk that is not a good idea we are
asking you to reconsider that decision
and to seek shelter in the West or
alternatively before the weather becomes
too severe to come into Freeport this is
not a time for us to seek to exist
forecasters say Dorian should turn north
hugging the east coast of Florida once
it passes over the Bahamas but risks
remain Florida Georgia and the Carolinas
are making last-minute preparations even
if Dorian remains on its predicted path
strong winds heavy rains and storm
surges could have a catastrophic impact
even the slightest deviation with a
storm this large ferocious and
slow-moving could be deadly
this storm at this magnitude could
really cause massive destruction and do
not put your life in jeopardy by staying
behind when you have a chance to get out
and you still do have time to prepare
yourself and to make sure that you and
your family are safe states of emergency
have now been declared in parts of
Florida Georgia and the Carolinas and
the dangers will remain for some time
the eye of Hurricane Dorian may remain
off the coast of Florida but much of the
state is still inside the cone of
uncertainty from its formation Dorian
has surprised forecasters strengthening
significantly on Sunday morning the
first outer bands are expected here late
on Monday and into Tuesday or millions
can do now is watch and wait as this
huge storm creeps closer to the US all
eyes are on the Bahamas with significant
damages already being reported the next
few days could prove devastating I have
brought everything
but my house which I still don't think I
brought enough but we don't know how
long we're gonna be here so we have to
take whatever precautions having our
water whenever little Netflix you can
have but I think the thing of being
together here is nothing like no one
should be alone forecasters are warning
that durian may slow down even as it
grows in intensity some have described
the storm as textbook others say it's a
lingering monster that will threaten
lives for days and a Gallacher al
jazeera Miami Florida